el verano apenas inicia en el hemisferio
norte con termómetros desbordados como
en el centro y sureste de España que
sufre su primera ola de calor de la
temporada con temperaturas de hasta 44
grados centígrados y con La amenaza de
ser uno de los países europeos más
afectados por el cambio climático
Mientras tanto sus ciudadanos sienten
los efectos poco porque es como un
bochorno que
te cansa y yo encima trabajo también en
la calle y así pero al final es como te
acostumbras o si no pues piensas que
como lo tienes que hacer Igual estar por
la calle así pues como que me acostumbro
y me mentalizo muy triste es el cambio
climático
y Tendremos que irnos acostumbrando
desgraciadamente en 2022 España tuvo el
verano más cálido en los últimos 100
años causando 350 muertes por golpes de
calor entre mayo y agosto un 20.5% más
que en el mismo periodo de 2019
Al otro lado del mundo en Asia el verano
empezó batiendo récords en partes de
China como Beijing también en Vietnam en
hanoi donde las autoridades apagaron el
alumbrado público para mantener la red
eléctrica
y en Canadá la calidad del aire en la
ciudad de Montreal fue catalogada como
la peor del mundo debido a su más feroz
temporada de incendios forestales que ya
deja al menos 7 millones de hectáreas
quemadas en un poco más de un mes el
humo ha afectado a Chicago y Nueva York
y 24 millones de personas están bajo
alerta por la calidad del aire en
Estados Unidos
es como Niebla Solo que es uno de los
incendios es muy difícil respirar
también me pican los ojos es difícil ver
pero está bien con una máscara
el servicio meteorológico de Estados
Unidos ha mostrado su preocupación por
la llegada del fenómeno del niño que ya
empieza a mostrar sus primeras
consecuencias aumentando las
temperaturas de las aguas del Pacífico
un evento que podría tener consecuencias
aún más catastróficas en el clima y para
la salud humana